let's get back to the phones at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 a lot going on this week and a
lot of people who want to chime in let's
go next to our caller from the three one
three area code three one three what's
your name where are you calling from
today hey yeah this is Adam from
Michigan hey Adam what's up yeah yeah so
um I'm not really a like a Democrat but
I like some of their policies but one of
like one thing I really don't like is I
guess in both parties nobody talks about
reducing taxes did you say nobody talks
about reducing Texas the state of Texas
or taxes taxes taxes like yeah oh I
think both talk about reducing taxes
just for different different groups of
people typically well okay so I'll say I
mean like Texas um
they talk about the rich but like when
it comes to like the middle class you
know there is um even with Trump like
his tax plan they didn't change much so
um cuz I come yeah so like um like the
you know they talk about like benefits
and stuff like that but you know like
the average person it's everything like
60k they're going to be paying like stay
you know federal local um could be like
15k in Texas and if you include like
stuff like prioritized year you're
paying like 20k so I see I see you guys
okay um you know like just any like
basic budgeting you know you got to
reduce your cost in like I see if X is
just one big castle and nobody's really
talking about reducing tax so hold on so
listen first of all everybody's talking
about reducing taxes the the battle is
over who are you going to reduce them
for now what you have to understand is
that if you're running for president all
you can do is deal with with this at the
federal level right the federal tax
brackets separate from that some states
have a state income tax and some don't
there are cities that have city income
taxes in the United States there are
other ways that taxes are collected
there are sales taxes there are excise
taxes on vehicles property taxes often
places that have no state
contacts have a higher property tax but
that's decided either by States or
municipalities or the Secretary of State
so these are all different things but I
I think I take issue with your original
premise Republicans talked about
lowering taxes Democrats talked about
lowering taxes typically you know they
both want to make it seem as though
they're going to lower them on the
middle-class Republicans tend to lower
taxes on the very rich but everybody's
talking about taxes all the time my
friend no I mean like it's like so much
I guess what I'm trying to say is like
they're not saying all right like okay
like we're gonna reduce you're like
we're gonna make it like um cuz he like
isn't like what I want you know what I
want them to kind of say is like alright
if you make you know if you make under
50k you know you don't pay you like
anything today nobody's like really sit
there and that wouldn't work that would
be a busy thing to say that just
mathematically it wouldn't work we
wouldn't have roads we wouldn't have
police departments we wouldn't have
firefighters we wouldn't have you know
Center for Disease Control we wouldn't
have a military like I mean if just if
everybody making under fifty thousand
pay zero taxes we get rid of a whole
bunch of this stuff we have nobody
saying it because it would never work
well I mean that's I guess that's like
um I guess what I want to work isn't say
I kind of like the whole point of the
Democratic Party is like the rich are
going to pay for it yes when you know
what you when you look at the tax base
if you say everybody earning under fifty
thousand dollars a year pays no taxes of
any kind you destroy both federal state
and local budgets and and there's no
question that the very rich we have a
progressive system in the United States
at least for federal taxes the very rich
should be paying more somebody like
Bernie Sanders would have the rich
paying even more than they are but if
you go to zero taxes for everyone at 50k
you're decimating a whole bunch of
different budgets if you're including
all of the taxes that you listed or you
may be just like federal let's take the
federal for example if you say maybe
something like well my point is because
you're gonna need that money to survive
so like if like so this is this is how I
see I see it like like it's it's money
being swapped it's like you know you
give
because um the point of Texas it's for
the well-being but you know if you're
really struggling at 50 K like you're
not going to be you're gonna be
struggling at 50 K so if you yes like
right now like if you pay like 50 60 and
you're gonna be paying 20 K that's
that's a third of your budget that's
gone so yeah you might have a road but
guess what you're not gonna have a car
you're not gonna you know you're not
you're not going to benefit from a
disaster so that's kind of yeah so
listen I I think we're we can agree is I
I'm open to the idea of eggs of
federally exempting more income from
taxation but the idea of zero taxes
across the board for everybody 50 K and
under I don't think it would quite work
but listen I I appreciate the call I'll
give it more thought I I'm gonna hear
from a few other people but a very very
interesting idea